[Musique]
vous devez certainement vous demander ce
qui se passe il y a à peine une minute
j'étais avec mon frère charlie c'est
magique massari fais pas ça
et maintenant nous voilà
je vais être clair nous entrons dans une
zone de danger dans ce monde il faut
jamais se fier aux apparences nous de
vous retrouver mon petit frère
il se passe que des trucs dedans ma foi
que je trouve de l'aide
je vous paierai un bon prix hawaï en
hausse
football pour toi j'ai des contacts un
petit peu partout alors prêt pour le fun
[Applaudissements]
respirez passe
suivez-moi
c'est vrai c'est que pour les ordures la
charrette
[Applaudissements]
elle arrive elle arrive elle arrive elle
arrive à larry david